[Music]
humans have always taught meaning beyond
themselves and stories about the gods
and the beyond
yet today contemporary culture and
thought has left many alone with only
human and contradictory perspectives on
the universe
in the absence of something beyond
ourselves some would argue we have also
lost meaning and purpose
do we need the transcendental to give
our lives meaning can we conjure a 21st
century form of the transcendental in
the philosophical mysteries of life and
the universe
or should we wing out a niche and cheer
at the death of god and focus our
attention on creating our own human
meanings that have lasting value and
importance
welcome to this morning's event
and let me introduce our speakers
rupert sheldrake is a biologist author
and parapsychology researcher
best known for his hypothesis of morphic
resonance rupert has sold authored nine
books his most recent being ways to go
beyond and why they work
maria balaska is a philosopher at the
university of hertfordshire and author
of the book wittgenstein and lachon at
the limit meaning and astonishment
and last but not least james tartalia
is a british philosopher and author of
the book philosophy in a meaningless
life
his main interest is in understanding
and enhancing awareness of the nature of
philosophical inquiry
so we will start with opening pictures
from our three speakers in response to
the question do we need the
transcendental to give our lives meaning
rupert
well a lot of people don't have a sense
of the transcendental most people in
britain describe themselves as
non-religious
and
many have been brought up with a secular
and materialist world view
which tells us that
the universe is made of unconscious
matter evolution is purposeless the mind
is nothing but the brain or the activity
of the brain and it all goes blank when
you die
now lots of people find that reasonably
okay and lead satisfactory lives
um
however
i think one of the consequences of this
is a proneness to depression and i think
most modern secular societies are
blighted by sort of huge levels of
depression and people on antidepressants
if you look at the middle ages when
there was a shared view and a shared
belief in transcendence they produced
with a tiny population here in britain
the great cathedrals like canterbury and
lincoln and wells and so on uh there was
a shared meaning
and a
shared creation of great buildings well
of course we have great buildings too
mainly banks
i think the first point is some people
it's perfectly fine the way it is
however if one looks at the actual
things that change people's lives
looking at the natural history of
life-changing events
a study started over 50 years ago by sir
ellis de hardy at oxford
it turns out that what people find
really meaningful are things like
near-death experiences spontaneous
mystical experiences
spiritual practices and today
increasingly psychedelic experiences
also there are many spiritual
practices which can
make it easier for these spiritual
experiences to happen these experiences
of connectedness
i've written about them in my recent
books things like meditation prayer
rituals connecting with nature
and indeed
sport which is one of the ways in which
people in the modern world achieve
altered states of consciousness
meditation is all about coming into the
present because you only have that
experience of presence of the greater
consciousness in the present
and it works reasonably well i meditate
myself but sports uh bring people into
the present instantly as a friend of
mine said he tried meditating when he
was very very busy and his mind was
racing didn't work for him he's a rock
climber there and he said by the time he
was 50 feet up a rock face he was
totally in the present someone's skiing
downhill at 60 miles an hour is totally
in the present someone in the middle of
a football match is totally in the
present so i think actually there are
many hidden forms of connection with the
spiritual realm and the sense of a
greater presence in the modern world
despite the secular facade
so i think we do need this if we want to
have a deeper sense of meaning and i
think even in a secular world where
religion has much less role to play for
most people
the need for these experiences generates
a quest for them and people find them in
all sorts of different ways thanks
rupert over to you maria do we need the
transcendental to give our lives meaning
i think i need to draw a distinction
between the transcendent and the
transcendental to answer the question
so in ordinary language we use the word
transcendent and the word transcendental
is synonymous but in philosophy they're
not so the transcendent refers to a
reality that transcends our own reality
that extends beyond our own reality
the usual candidate for that would be
god
but the transcendental doesn't need to
refer to something otherworldly like god
to something that transcends the reality
but it can just refer to our own
concepts and categories insofar as they
are
important for
sense mating itself let me give an
example to explain so we have concepts
that describe things that we find in the
world like for example the concept of a
lemon or a glass or a table but then
we've got concepts that do not describe
things in the world yet they describe
things that are necessary for us to make
sense of the world like the concept of
good or beautiful or concepts in
mathematics or in logic or the concept
of a world itself or life if by that we
mean life as a whole we don't find this
um whole anywhere in the world
so if that's what we mean by the
transcendental then i think that the
question of the meaning of life cannot
but be situated within the
transcendental if by transcendental we
mean the transcendent i think it can but
it doesn't have to
thanks maria and finally james
well i don't think we need to give our
lives meaning at all because they're
already packed full of the stuff there's
football meaning office work meaning
festival meaning restaurant meaning
humans create meaning by taking on
projects we want to do something we make
that our goal that becomes our purpose
as we pursue that goal things take on a
meaning in relation to it you know that
helps me that's an opportunity
that's an obstacle that's a disaster and
we change this as as we go through our
lives right we're always adjusting our
goals sometimes we've got lots on at the
same time so the idea of picking out one
meaning as you know the meaning of a
person's life strikes me as hopeless
uh i mean here's an example right if we
were to think about um some great
artists who lived hundreds of years ago
we'd naturally say well the meaning of
his life was provided by the art the
great art arty produce and thereby we
maybe miss out this guy's happy family
life you know think how much meaning
that can involve or uh maybe his last
ten years which he spent in poverty
so as far as individual
lives are concerned i think that idea of
meaning is just entirely interest
relative
and that's why people talk across
purposes in these debates if you're
talking about the human race
i don't think there's any master plan
that we're trying to fulfill
i don't think that there's anything that
humanity is supposed to be doing
um i don't you know see any problem with
that whatsoever of course many people in
the world do think that there is some
master plan that we're all following
most people in the world are religious
but i would say this if there is
such a grand evaluative context for our
lives a meaning of life then it could be
either good or bad right it could be
horrible and nobody's ever been able to
give any remotely plausible idea of what
this meaning would be so there's no
reason to think it would be
good rather than bad
if nihilism is true on the other hand
okay
it can't be either good or bad it's just
a fact about our reality because it
denies this notion of meaning as an
evaluation
now the notion of nihilism was first
introduced in the 1790s alongside the
notion of the meaning of life they came
together the good and the bad guy and
nihilism's got very bad press ever since
then but it seems to me that if you
don't really believe in judging a
person's whole life
which you know i wouldn't like to
somebody to judge my life right okay if
you think that's baseless and probably
kind of harmful practice
and if you don't think there's any grand
master plan that's drawing us forward
then i would recommend to you nihilism
and the correct understanding
thanks james i want to push you a bit
harder on that in relation to our first
theme which is
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai dot tv
for more debates and talks from the
world's leading thinkers on today's
biggest ideas
you